oh well let's flip camera what's going
on guys I'm at YouTube space la right
now I got 20% battery I'm smart smart
one of the few people actively decide to
do a livestream Wow board a youtube
space with only 20% battery that's how I
roll
thanks David right happy to be here I'm
dressed up because I'm going to being a
sketch with Lauren Francesca my
brother's gonna be here too and he's in
there somewhere
knowing him he'll get the notification
that I'm live stream right now they
didn't want to be in the video no way
that guy anyway yeah right now just uh
when people shoot professional [ __ ]
it gets very boring waiting around and
I'll I got two hours of sleep cuz I
stressed about having to be here on time
and knowing my luck I will I will be
here when the infinity war trailer
surprisingly drops tonight and I'm not
gonna be able to be around for it anyway
what's going on in the livestream
comments people what's going on the
livestream comment suit-and-tie yeah I'm
part of the I'm part of this sketch
right now dela thank you thank you
look how snazzy I look look how snazzy I
look oh yeah oh yeah here's a little
behind the scenes I got a hole in my
pants this ain't the first livestream
I'm doing gunslinger they say it the
first livestream I'm doing I'm by myself
I have less than two hours of sleep and
I got three lines in this thing but now
I'm really having a beer it's really
cool see is I want my Lauren Lauren
Francesca they're putting together a
really professional sketch right now and
full crew and everything and they're
shooting at YouTube space but when
you're just an actor and you're not
involved in anything else a lot of it is
just waiting around so here I am I can't
smoke weed right now
Randy I can't it's too early in the
morning to smoke too early Gabriel
Gonzalez I'd say the majority of people
think Lauren's pretty hot
I found this tie in a box the other day
apparently about this tie Forever Ago
2020 and Poland come on guys what's
going on with the comets that Dana
oh here you're a gorgeous follower
gunslinger Ellie Hendricks hello tank oh
I know I look like I'm high it's because
I have less than two hours of sleep is
she coming to the live stream no she's
filming she's directing and everything
I'm out here because like I said the
theme of today's live stream is abord
eat some trail mix I have like 15
percent battery by the way guys but I
wanted to take this time to interact
with you all to let you know why uploads
actually I have a video ready to publish
it's a reaction to how it should have
ended its villain but video waiting to
publish that run yeah so let me ask you
guys what more on the channel which you
guys like to see put more on the channel
would you guys like to see maybe I can
start using a little bit more of that
Cameron what's good buddy I'll tell you
what's good life Trump is president
everything is on the up and up right now
more skits skits are hard to do you know
how long that Greg saw sketch took us to
do like we had to put that sketch
together in between uploading YouTube
videos and taking care of patreon
handling personal life and also so we
would be up to like really late at night
putting that thing together I look hella
thin huh thank you thank you you know
I'm the first person ever to livestream
at YouTube space I think no other
youtuber has ever done this more try not
to laugh those are awesome those are
awesome
you always get a really thorough
in-depth discussion there's not much you
can really say in those videos I don't
really think there's much content I only
do them every once in a while because I
know for some reason people really like
you in them but yeah Chris pagan you
stopped bitching [ __ ] I do
sketches whenever I really feel like
doing them we do a few of them a year so
shut your mouth [ __ ]
where's John here to censor me when I
need him more fancy hats I only have one
beanie that's a Batman beanie
Benji James been a long time since I've
seen you man
Chris pagan it's my honor to curse you
out piers you call me daddy how'd you
know I like being called daddy piers
Majan now I would say my favorite movie
is the matrix I think that movie has it
all I think the movie has it all
to be honest daddy oh oh gosh I'm so I
just really just really want a film
already just wondering what's going on
Coenen most of time when I upload conan
videos i Babak Conan's that rare thing
where I can actually create a discussion
out of a Conan video when you think you
can't but most of the time Team Coco
actually blocks the videos there's
plenty of requests that you guys put out
I don't know if you guys know this but
there's plenty of requests you guys put
like a lot of people asked us to do at
the Thor 4d and we shot it and we it's
up on our patreon because whenever it
gets blocked we put up on our patreon
for the lowest reward tier which is only
a dollar but yeah that got blocked
instantly like the second it was
uploaded it was blocked I haven't seen
the Warcraft thing honestly people want
me to be a major gamer but I'm not I'm
not
it's what Tyrone Magnus is for yeah I'm
actually really hyped for Justice League
I'm really excited you know
John and I did those movie clips and
reactions and discussions and I ended up
just watching all of them over again on
my own like this looks so cool I haven't
seen the new Colbert Conan interview I
might want to check that out actually it
seems like a fun thing I'm wondering
though guys like you know if there were
more topics though if there were other
topics maybe that were not reactions
alone but if there were other topics you
guys would like to hear us do you on
that would be that would be fun to do
you know is YouTube's very strict now
I'm at YouTube right now I'm telling you
they're very strict YouTube you're very
strict is a YouTube building
very stretchy barely put anything up now
a lot of youtubers complain about this
thumb couple yellow dollar bills sign
and once you get that it means a lot of
your subscribers might not even get
notified your video is out a lot of them
might not even get notified so that's
why you'll see channels bigger than our
subscriptions didn't do the NAR doesn't
have like million followers and then
their views get like 20,000 30,000 views
out of a million it's crazy
that's crazy it's crazy I'm here today
because I love you David Allen I came
out this year I think my favorite album
that came out this year will be the
Eminem album that is dropping
real people I still got to put together
my reaction reviews for stranger things
- and they're all shot I would probably
give it a 7.5 honestly I probably get
stranger things at 7.5 not the biggest
fan of it yo
did everyone leave or is it just a
really bad connection here favorite Star
Wars film Empire Strikes Back and you
know what I feel like I'm gonna need a
lot of crap for this I really love the
[ __ ] at a rogue one ungraded as my
number two favorite
what's a WWE react reacting to WWE the
wrestling yeah it's funny people are
complaining about the stream going
offline every once in a while and I'm
logged into YouTube's actual Wi-Fi and
somehow the the Wi-Fi is bad hello
Illinois phishing one-on-one pleasure to
see you again buddy
what's a neck reveal Thank You Anthony
Avila I appreciate that
one of these days I'm just gonna do a
live stream where I just stare but the
questions that not actually talked did I
lose caught gamers respect because I
have my own opinion about rogue what
what what just happened what just I need
your respect maybe I should just keep
changing my opinions to keep everyone
happy
hey Justina Chris pagan maybe we should
collapse send me a photo of your ass I
don't let you know sorry I didn't mean
to make up a joke like that with all
these harsh holy what times were going
through fishing 101 this channel loves
you I can see your comments they they're
coming in periodically
I okay if Casey missed it I'm very
excited for justice Lee John's at home
he's probably sleeping
that's so I've noticed with John usually
wakes up between the 11 to 12 hour is a
very productive man I hope he watches
this like I'm dressed up because I'm
gonna be in a sketch I'm filming a
YouTube space right now I know some
people join in a little bit later so
have to keep informing them what's my
battery level that I'm at like like a 5
percent right now I'm just waiting for
my battery to die can you make a video
without a shirt on you know ever isn't I
lost like 40 pounds this year actually I
lost close to 40 pounds sometimes
depending on water weight I have lost 40
pounds but I don't know I'm kind of
waiting to get like a little bit more
cut like you know actually muscular
instead of like my right now my body is
impressive for what it used to look like
but I wanted to just be naturally
impressive I tied it myself that's how
rich man has a time on the Fogo all
right it's at 3% another thing I'm gonna
say buy in this last year there cuz you
know way for my phone to die thanks Tony
that's a great name John is one of the
coolest dudes I've ever known the guy
for 20-something years it's one of the
best guys my phone dies I don't know how
say goodbye just let me say goodbye in
advance because I'm at 2% battery 2% and
like the smart youtuber I am I did not
bring a phone charger with me today hey
razor vid yeah that's my real Twitter
thanks Scott gamer I guess I guess I've
earned some of your respect back again
after saying I I loved rogue 1 mile of
road 1
love it you know else I love you know
else like [ __ ] love wild wild west I
think that's a hilarious film and I
think people should stop giving in crap
and you know what else I think instead
of watching Murder on the Orient Express
tonight I'm gonna wash daddy's home -
because I watched daddy's home again
last night and I forgot how [ __ ]
funny that movie was when we'll let you
live again I don't know I don't know
thanks Justine oh you're such a sweet
girl
it's nice to see when girls are a common
team here we got oh if you look at our
analytics it's like a 99% demographic
yeah are we looking for me I'm about to
film finally yeah all right I gotta go
guys see ya
perfect time